Speaker 1: It's great to welcome to the program
today.
Oren Etzioni, who's the founding CEO of the
Allen Institute for Artificial Intelligence.
Really appreciate your time today.
Thank you.
Speaker 4: It's my pleasure.
Good.
Always good to talk to humans.
Speaker 1: Is that right?
So, I mean, okay, let's first for some in
our audience who maybe have a general sense
of the idea of artificial intelligence, the
term machine learning, which I know you have,
you have a particular opinion about and these
sorts of issues.
I think they may have a general awareness
that there are people who are very scared
about the potential of an artificial general
intelligence, and there are others who have
a very optimistic view of those same possibilities
as maybe bringing Homo sapiens to a new level
of learning and capabilities and medical advancements,
etc..
Can you kind of lay out the the goalposts
or the guideposts as the term may be, of the
perspectives on this issue, those who are
pessimistic versus optimistic?
What is the crux of this disagreement?
Speaker 4: Well, the way I think about it
is that the computer is a pencil.
It's a very big pencil.
It's a very sophisticated tool, is what I'm
trying to say.
And as with any powerful tool, it can be used
for good or for better.
So there are people who worry about its impact
on jobs, losing jobs, on privacy, losing privacy,
the bias that it potentially can exhibit in
its algorithms.
So that's on the one side.
And then there are people who can see its
potential for discovering vaccines like the
COVID vaccine.
And I help there and see that benefit.
There's also a group of people who really
don't think of it as a tool.
They think that somehow this pencil is going
to escape and become a death star.
And I a little bit mocking of that point of
view, because I think that it really is just
a tool.
Speaker 1: That's super interesting because
it's we'll get to the why.
I might be an exception, but in Neil Postman's
book Technopolis, which I think is from the
early nineties, he has a very similar perspective
in general about new technologies, which is
there's sometimes this idea of new technology
comes forward.
Some people theorize or speculate about possible
negative consequences.
The next step is, well, let's figure out a
way to get the positive, but not the negative.
And his view is all the positive and negative
will all exist.
It's a question of implementation, regulation,
planning and management, essentially, that
you can't only have the good without the bad.
Where some say A.I. is different is at least
the theoretical ability of an artificial general
intelligence to learn more quickly, more rapidly,
in a way that gets it beyond whatever its
sort of initial.
I don't even know if programing is the right
term.
You'll tell me if that's even the right word
to use.
And so it's sort of outside of, you know,
social media.
Social media is created.
It exists within certain bounds.
It will have good and bad.
And we can regulate and manage the difference,
at least in theory, with artificial intelligence
would be that it can itself go beyond the
guidelines and the borders that humans set
for it.
Does that make it different?
Speaker 4: Well, let's first of all, start
with the fact that there is a universal and
understandable fear about our role as humans
and technology.
And this goes all the way back to the Jewish
legend of the Golem, who is this robot into
Frankenstein and so on.
So for centuries we've been worried in various
ways that technology is going to have this
outsized role.
Now, it is possible.
It is conceivable that one day that'll happen.
So now the question is how close or far away
from that apocalyptic vision?
And my assessment as somebody who's been working
on this for 30 years and who's very steeped
in this technology, seeing the latest thing,
as I was just a few days ago is Chat GPT,
which is this program.
You can have these amazing exchanges with
me.
Maybe we'll talk about that.
But my assessment is that we are still decades,
if not centuries away from that vision.
So really what A.I. is today is a lot more
like the next generation of software.
So, again, super powerful changing the world,
you know, your your iPhone and so on, but
still very much a tool that we can use.
And the notion that it will somehow escape.
And become a lot more than we expect.
It's not really based on data.
It's based on excited.
When you look at the data, when you look at
what these computers can do, they're amazing,
but they're not autonomous.
Right.
Even take the the notion of self-driving cars,
autonomous vehicles, other than the fact that
they're not yet ready for primetime and effective.
You still tell the car where to go, right?
It'll keep you safer than ever eventually,
but it doesn't suddenly decide.
Okay, you know, I want to go to Cleveland.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
And I can tell you, as a Tesla driver, it's
not exactly something to write home about
right now.
The technology, which which I know you're
aware of, there are some who I don't know
if are actually taken seriously by folks like
you, like Ray Kurzweil, who for more than
a decade has been saying we're actually now
in that phase that you say is decades or even
maybe hundreds of years away.
We just can't tell because when you're in
the middle of rapid change, it just seems
slower.
And in retrospect, we will realize it.
You don't agree with that?
You don't believe that that time you're describing
is taking place right now.
Speaker 4: I not only not agree with that,
but again, I caution to look at the data.
Right.
So what is Kurzweil, who, again, has an impressive
history in technology?
What's his basis for saying that?
And you can also look at him saying a number
of other amazing things, like we've reached
the point where we're going to live forever.
And so I would say that he's a very optimistic
individual.
Fair.
Speaker 1: Okay.
That's that that's fair to say.
Let's talk a little bit about you mentioned
the chat technology.
The Turing test is for those who are not familiar,
sort of an idea of when does an artificial
when does an AI type technology get good enough
at mimicking human conversation such that
an actual human like you or I wouldn't be
able to tell that we are not speaking to another
human.
And what folks wrote in and they said, well,
you know, you should ask about are Siri and
Alexa like that?
I think the answer is it's certainly not right,
is it?
Would you agree that they are not at that
level?
Speaker 4: Siri intellects are are very simple,
but this is something that's rapidly changing.
Changing.
So Chad, GPT, which is this new chat bot considered
the best chat bot ever.
It's reached more than a million users in
five days.
Yeah.
Freely available on the internet.
That one is getting close to passing the fabled
Turing test.
Speaker 1: Is that.
As big a milestone as decades of literature
make it out to be?
Or is it a curiosity that is self-contained
enough that it does not necessarily mean.
Okay.
Now that gets us to some particular next level.
Speaker 4: That is a great, great question.
And I think the answer is that we've learned
that various limits that we've set where we
believe, gosh, a computer will never do that,
get crossed.
And that's in 1997, a computer beating Garry
Kasparov, the world champion.
And just right more recently, a few years
back, beating the world champion and go.
There was a recent computer program that plays
the strategy game of diplomacy, and now we
have the Turing test.
But each time we realize that the computer
is picking up an aspect of intelligence, but
not the whole human level thing.
And so particularly about the Turing test,
New York Times reporter John Markoff said
that the Turing test is a test of human gullibility.
Right.
So it is interacting in a way that seems human,
but the these programs don't really understand
what's going on.
Speaker 1: When we think about the different
ways that artificial intelligence at a level
that's slightly ahead of where it is now,
but not yet at what you're describing to be
decades or hundreds of years away.
When we think about some of those possibilities,
there's all sorts of different fields that
we could talk about.
If we talk about the medical field and the
idea of using machine learning or whatever
better term we may have for it, as well as
big data when it comes to patient data and
learning an algorithm of questions that could
be answered by a potential patient, the idea
of incredibly accurate diagnosis often comes
up in lots of literature as a as a use for
this type of technology, and that it would
take out the emotion that that is there to
some degree and a so-called real doctor, and
that there's other benefits in the field of
medicine specifically.
Is that interesting to you?
Is it likely or is there something big that's
missing from those hypotheses that actually
makes that not a very likely outcome in the
next 5 to 10 years with such technology?
Speaker 4: I think this is a great example
of how powerful and beneficial computers can
be along two dimensions.
First of all, we can get much better diagnoses,
as you suggested, based on more data and more
analysis.
And secondly, we can also make it much more
widely available.
There's so many rural areas, remote countries
and regions where the kind of medicine that
we're used to is just not available.
And it's it's expensive to do it with humans.
So if we can build programs accessible over
the Internet, that can help, that's fantastic.
Now, I think that the best use of this, certainly
in the foreseeable future, isn't just the
computer taking over completely.
But my favorite definition of A.I. is not
artificial intelligence, it's augmented intelligence.
So imagine that you have a doctor with their
experience, with their empathy, being aided
with this indefatigable assistant that reads
all the millions, literally millions of papers
coming out that's gathering all these statistics
and that's making recommendations to the doctor.
Would you rather have your human doctor or
your human doctor with this incredible tool
at their disposal?
It's a no brainer.
Speaker 1: It is, I guess, to play devil's
advocate, the trend of doctors sitting there
looking at a screen rather than the patient
is already pretty bad.
And and if the logistics of having the AI
help have them more sucked into the computer
screen, maybe the experience won't be better,
but maybe the outcome would.
I don't know.
Speaker 4: Well, again, wonderful point.
But I would say this ultimately, we do care
more about the outcome, particularly when
it comes to critical things.
But to the reason that they're on the computer
so much is because they have all this paperwork
to fill out.
Yes.
This is not a product of the I know a systems
are coming out right now that actually help
to automatically fill out the paperwork.
So I think in the very near future, we'll
have the computer less sorry, we'll have the
Dr. Interesting slip that will have the doctor
less on their computer doing that and more
able to engage with with the patient.
Speaker 1: I think I think that would be that
would be a good thing.
Last thing I want to ask you about there.
All of these issues ultimately end up being
political, right?
STEM cell research becomes political and so
does vaccines and everything becomes political.
Is it safe to assume and or is it already
happening that the political lines around
AI are that those who are more conservative
in their worldview are against this type of
technology?
They want to try to ban it in advance or prevent
its development, and that those who are more
socially liberal or progressive are more open
to it.
Or is it falling along different political
lines?
Speaker 4: Wow.
I've never been asked that question.
So, David, wonderful question.
And it is actually scrambling the political
spectrum.
And let me quickly illustrate why.
Yeah.
On the liberal side, there's a lot of concern
about bias, racism, sexism.
And these computer programs is they programs
are data based and so they sometimes absorb
bias from their data.
So there's a lot of concern there.
And on the conservative side, there's a lot
of concern about geopolitical tension and
the fact that China and others are attempting
to become superpowers, if not dominant in
Asia.
And so there's a very strong sense that we
need to invest heavily in it, both for economic
reasons and for national security.
So there are people all over the spectrum
and it doesn't break out neatly.
Speaker 1: We have been speaking with Dr.
Oren Etzioni, who's the founding CEO of the
Allen Institute for Artificial Intelligence.
Super interesting.
And I really appreciate your time today and
joining me.
Speaker 4: Thank you so much.